deuxième partie de la voie libre
effectivement en direct depuis la
préfecture de Dijon sur les conséquences
de la fusion entre la Bourgogne et la
Franche-Comté conséquence surtout sur
les administrations et sur les services
de l'État avec vos questions les
questions que vous avez posées ces
derniers jours et pendant le première
partie de l'émission sur nos deux sites
internet en Bourgogne en
franche-comtéale
je vous représente nos invités donc
évidemment puisque c'est eux qui ont été
posées les questions d'abord Eric
Delzant préfet de Bourgogne préfet
préfigurateur de Bourgogne Franche-Comté
également sur ce plateau dans les salons
de la préfecture de Dijon Dominique
Aubry Frelin secrétaire régional de la
CFDT en Franche-Comté en charge du
dossier réforme territorial Ludovic
Rochette vous êtes président de
l'Association des maires de Côte-d'Or et
vous appartenez au parti les
républicains Jean-Luc piton le président
du Medef de Franche-Comté et puis
Christian Magnin faiso président de
laruca Franche-Comté c'est une
association des usagers des services de
soins alors madame messieurs une
première question de Tassy envoyé cette
semaine
quels seront les dispositifs de
formation mise en place pour aider les
fonctionnaires pour leur reconversion et
pour leur charge changement de service
si les postes sont fusionnés et donc
supprimer
est essentielle on peut pas imaginer
demander aux gens d'évoluer dans leur
métier sans accompagner cette évolution
de formation on a des dispositifs qui
existent déjà des dispositifs plus
importants qui vont se mettre en place
ça a été anticipé oui bien sûr un
accompagnement individualisé de
l'ensemble des agents évidemment on peut
pas faire se former nouvellement un
agent tant qu'il ne connaît pas sa
future affectation mais en même temps on
va avoir une période transitoire quand
je disais tout à l'heure ça se met en
place ce 1er janvier 2016 la réforme
elle aura sa complétude fin 2018 donc on
a trois ans pour que tout ça fonctionne
j'allais dire à plein rendement on va
pas demander aux gens encore une fois
entre le 31 décembre et le 1er janvier
d'avoir complètement tout changé donc il
faut que les fonctionnaires à cet égard
soit rassuré
des dispositifs individuels et
collectifs seront mis en place pour leur
permettre de s'adapter à la fois à leur
nouvelle mission et à leur nouvelle
organisation Jean-Luc piton il y a pas
d'inquiétude pour vous parce qu'on sait
que le monde de l'entreprise parfois a
besoin de réponse rapide sur un certain
nombre de sujets dossiers quand on
entend la réforme elle doit aller
trouver sa complétude d'un 2018 non par
rapport à ça il y a pas d'inquiétude
parce que on sait que les il y a une
certaine pérennité en France des
services de l'État
et non je pense que simplement à partir
de la formation c'est un sujet essentiel
et je pense qu'il y aura également des
besoins de formation pour que les gens
apprennent à travailler ensemble parce
que bon l'état ça sera peut-être plus
facile dans les directions puisque il y
a quand même une organisation nationale
de l'État en France qui est très forte
mais toutes les organismes qui dépendent
de l'état ont chacun dans leur
localisation des méthodes et des façons
de fonctionner très différentes et avec
des gens qui ont des personnalités très
différentes et là on sent qu'il va être
un peu compliqué de les faire travailler
ensemble et on espère d'ailleurs qu'il
peut y avoir un des services marchands
en matière de formation avec des
sociétés extrêmement compétentes dans le
domaine privé qui pourrait venir aider
l'État et on est tout à fait petite
propositions
que cette dimension formation soit prise
en charge enfin soit envisager bien
entendu après ça dépendra aussi de
l'ampleur du des moyens mis la formation
qu'elle soit faite en interne ou en
externe ça a un coup et c'est
indispensable il y a un accompagnement
indispensable des agents on l'avait
évoqué un peu tout à l'heure mais j'ai
envie de vous le redemander de façon
claire est-ce que cette réforme dans la
vie quotidienne des agents de l'État ça
a suscité des inquiétudes du stress
est-ce que vous avez eu des remontées
parce que on apprend enfin les gens ont
appris du jour au lendemain qu'on
fusionner les deux régions et ça veut
dire que plein de chances plein de
choses allaient changer pour eux comme
ça du jour au lendemain vous avez des
remontées là-dessus les inquiétudes
c'est clair les inquiétudes elles se
elles seront jusqu'au 1er janvier mais
aussi comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure dans les trois ans à venir voire
plus puisque le changement sera
permanent mais le changement au
quotidien est-ce que je travaillerai à
peu près au même endroit c'est une vraie
inquiétude je vous parle pas des
fonctionnaires des conseils régionaux
qui doivent attendre les élections pour
avoir des réponses que les agents de
l'État commencent à avoir c'est encore
plus stressant on va reparler des agents
de l'État avec une question de Florence
concernant l'éducation nationale
Florence nous dit je suis allé faire un
tour sur le site internet de
l'inspection académique splendide lettre
du DA donc c'est le directeur académique
écrite à ces troupes pour leur annoncer
que tout change mais que rien ne change
alors effectivement l'éducation
nationale c'est un peu particulier
puisqu'on l'a vu en début d'émission il
y aura un rectorat de région à Besançon
et un rectorat quand même à Dijon vous
pouvez nous éclairer Eric Delzant tout
change mais rien de chance c'est ça
alors le choix qui a été fait par
l'Éducation nationale est effectivement
je crois tiens compte de la spécificité
de l'organisation de l'éducation
nationale et notamment du fait que les
enseignants souhaitent garder une
gestion de proximité
une gestion académique et rectorale et
donc c'est ce qui explique notamment qui
restera un recteur à Dijon mais l'INT
interlocuteur unique du futur préfet de
Bourgogne Franche-Comté sera bien le
recteur de Région a Besançon et y
compris en matière d'enseignement
supérieur par exemple donc je crois que
c'est plutôt pour tenir compte encore
une fois de la spécificité de
l'éducation nationale mais globalement
on aura bien un recteur de région qui
sera l'homologue du préfet de région les
luttes de rural que vous êtes quand on
parle d'éducation forcément il se sent
concernés parce que l'école fermeture
ouverture c'est c'est l'alpha et l'oméga
de tous les débuts d'années ça on est
encore dans ce contexte de rentrée
scolaire et effectivement une fermeture
de classe en plus unique c'est un drame
absolu dans une commune donc cette
structure là elle vous semble elle vous
semble positif
indispensable d'autant plus dans des
départements comme les nôtres en
Côte-d'Or où on a 710 communes et on a
une des des villages qui peuvent être là
d'avoir de garder cette proximité avec
l'Éducation nationale
un axiome pour nous
réagir merci effectivement la présence
le maintien d'un rectorat académique a
Besançon est en parfaite cohérent
cohérence avec la
présidente et la présence de la
communauté des universités et des
établissements qui est à Besançon et
aussi bien
Jean-Louis Fousseret le maire de
Besançon il tenait beaucoup en termes de
cohérence tout comme l'ensemble du
président de l'université de
Franche-Comté
nouvelle question allez Jérôme nous dit
justement c'est pas une question il nous
dit mais une inquiétude énorme en
ajoutant une fois de plus une couche aux
mille-feuille déjà bien trop garnie du
système français comment allez-vous nous
faire croire que vous ferez des
économies qui veut répondre nous y
revoilà aux économies justement on en
retire puisqu'on on mutualise en fusion
nationale Monsieur le Préfet j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on en retire puisqu'il y
aura quand même un recteur à Dijon oui
mais encore une fois on est dans une
logique de proximité de service mais
quand même à partir du moment où vous
aviez deux administrations régionales et
vous n'en avez plus qu'une j'appelle pas
ça une couche supplémentaire au
millefeuille
alors s'agissant de l'État bien sûr on a
gardé un niveau régional des niveaux
départementaux mais ça répond aussi à ce
qui a été dit tout au long de cette
émission de ce matin besoin de proximité
besoin de services publics à un moment
donné il faut choisir je crois quand
même que le choix il a été fait de la
simplification de la modernisation
et c'est ça qui va générer encore une
fois des économies tout en maintenant un
service public de qualité les économies
elles se font d'abord sur le nombre de
fonctionnaires c'est la masse salariale
qui pèse aujourd'hui
je suis pas le premier président de la
Cour des comptes mais vous avez qu'à
vous rapporter à ses propos non moi je
crois que c'est exactement je crois que
les économies elles ne se mesure aussi
bien en termes de évidemment d'effectif
mais aussi en termes de fonctionnement
on peut faire des économies
considérables en termes de
fonctionnement appartenant où on
modernise à partir du moment où
mutualise et je crois que c'est ça qu'il
faut avoir en tête c'est que ces
économies là c'est peut-être pas celle
qui font le plus de bruit mais c'est
celle qui sont les plus souvent vous les
avez chiffrées
écoutez c'est difficile de les chiffrer
aujourd'hui c'est plus facile de
chiffrer quand on dit bon on va
supprimer tant de fonctionnaires ça
représente tant par année ça c'est
facile à chiffrer c'est vrai que les
économies en termes de de
façon de travailler et de façon de
fonctionner honnêtement je ne les ai pas
chiffrés aujourd'hui parce qu'on n'a pas
abouti encore complètement notre projet
d'organisation mais je peux vous assurer
que le moment venu vous serez étonné
concrètement sur le cas de l'éducation
pardon excusez-moi juste une question
sur le cas d'éducation ça va être un
mode de fonctionnement différent est-ce
qu'il y a une dimension hiérarchique
entre le recteur de la Grande Région et
le recteur de l'autre région est-ce que
le maire d'une commune il s'adresse à
quel rectorat finalement et qui aura
gain de cause il y aura toujours
l'organisation départementale la
direction des services départementaux de
l'éducation nationale
ensuite un recteur qui aura finalement
une relation privilégiée avec ses
directeurs départementaux quant à la
relation entre recteurs de région et
autres réacteurs le gouvernement doit
prochainement prendre un décret qui
réglera cette question je me garderai
bien d'anticiper sur ce décret ce matin
il suffit-on vous lirez je voulais
revenir sur le cas de des universités de
Bourgogne et Franche-Comté qui me semble
là l'État a comment je dirais il y a eu
une sorte d'appel c'est-à-dire que il y
a un an et demi l'État a imposé aux
universités d'avoir un site commun dans
un certain nombre de régions et
notamment en Bourgogne et Franche-Comté
la solution qui à l'époque a été choisie
a été de créer une super structure en
plus si aujourd'hui on avait à refaire
ce qui a été fait il y a un an et demi
probablement les tâches choisiraient de
dire en fusionne les deux universités de
telle sorte qu'il y ait une économie
réelle d'organisation qui puisse mettre
en place aujourd'hui on constate quoi on
constate que cette commune dont vous
parlez qui est quelque chose d'important
qui qui permet une concertation entre
les deux universités et dans notre futur
région Bourgogne Franche-Comté qui sera
quand même une des dernières en PIB par
habitant au même niveau que l'accord
c'est à dire vraiment enfin de classe la
recherche publique des grandes régions
je crois qu'on peut le dire la recherche
publique c'est quelque chose de très
important et donc effectivement
aujourd'hui on va voir une super
structure qui est la commu
dont acte le coup est parti je cherche
pas à dire qu'il faut qu'il faut
aujourd'hui faire machine arrière
rapidement mais on sait que ça génère
des une structure en plus des coups en
plus c'est une complexité en plus mais
Jean-Luc piton est-ce que là on n'est
pas parce que la fusion des universités
c'est quand même un serpent de mer entre
nos deux régions depuis des années et ce
qu'on n'est pas là dans aussi le
sempiternel sentiment d'infériorité des
franc-comtois à l'égard de la Bourgogne
et les Byzantins ont toujours peur de se
faire avaler tout cru par les Dijonnais
il est certain que discussion qui a eu
lieu entre les deux universités pour
aboutir
au cahier des charges de la de la copie
à la création de la commune au statut la
discussion sur les statuts a été très
longue très compliquée avec un certain
nombre d'éléments
comment je dirais de rapports de force
bien évidemment mais je pense que
l'intérêt de ce genre de démarche
également c'est que les deux organismes
à prendre à se connaître et que
l'intérêt de la réforme l'objectif de la
réforme c'est ce qu'on en fera c'est à
dire si on aboutirait au fait que les
gens tirent ensemble dans le même sens
et arrivent à se mettre d'accord sur des
projets des enjeux et ne reste pas sur
des positions de tranchées en disant
nous on fait comme ça on est les
meilleurs ici et n'arrivent pas à
discuter alors pour la dernière question
des internautes en s'éloigner un peu des
services de l'État parce que il y a une
question de Pascal qui me semble très
intéressante et enfin une question
inédite il est logique que le siège du
futur conseil régional soit à Dijon
chef-lieu de la Grande Région
l'amphithéâtre pour accueillir santé est
déjà existant et à 5 minutes à pied
seulement de la préfecture tout autre
choix serait à mes yeux pur mascarade
politicienne qu'en pensez-vous
en fait avec
cette question parce qu'elle appartient
aux élus que les électeurs auront choisi
au mois de les 6 et 13 décembre donc
c'est pas représentant de l'État de
d'anticiper sur cette réponse Ludovic
Rochet l'élu que vous êtes vous avez une
opinion j'imagine bien sûr même si je ne
voterai pas
en janvier prochain bien sûr que le
choix logique c'est facile pour vol de
dire c'est ce serait Dijon juste parce
que aussi avec la présence d'un scar qui
sera à Dijon il me semblerait logique de
cette proximité générale pour les
affaires régionales voilà donc un
interlocuteurs régional et bien tout ça
pourra nous faire office de conclusion
puisque nous arrivons en termes de cette
de cette émission merci à tous les cinq
d'être venu débattre d'être venu
expliquer sujet qui n'est pas forcément
connu tout le monde pour l'instant merci
Eric delzan de nous avoir accueilli dans
cette préfecture de Bourgogne et on va
continuer à se retrouver très régul
légèrement pour des débats bien sûr sur
la Bourgogne et la Franche-Comté des
débats qui vont nous mener jusqu'aux
élections
de décembre samedi prochain pas de voix
est Libre car tout le week-end sera
consacré aux Journées du Patrimoine bon
weekend au revoir et merci